some say that the theater is dead and
that is probably because most playhouses
the world over are closed at the moment
owing to a worldwide pandemic and yet
the musical lives on
on disney plus as the nation has been
wrapped with a filmed version of the
broadway smash hit
hamilton but this show wouldn't have
even been a twinkle in broadway's eye
if it weren't for the fact that composer
slash lyricist
human embodiment of theater kid energy
glenn manuel miranda
hadn't stumbled upon a copy of the
biography he used as the basis for the
show
ron chernos alexander hamilton
hamilton the musical is not based on the
life of
this guy it's based on this book though
it seems like an unlikely topic for a
musical miranda had this to say about
the process of adapting it
in a conversation with legendary
broadway composer stephen sondheim
well that leads me to a really good bit
of advice you gave me early when i was
writing hamilton
i was drowning in research and what you
told me was
just write the parts you think are a
musical and
that forms its own spine and it had us
come to the realization that a lot of
the bread and butter of musical theater
is built off of
books and so like every television
program that starts looking for new
ideas
it's finally come to this the it's lit
musical episode
at its best a musical uses all its
mediums to maximum effect
writing dialogue singing dancing
lighting and so on
it knows when to use a song and when to
pull back it knows when to go ham on the
acting and when to
not do that but since you have to be a
master of so many schools
it could be argued that that's why
musicals are so difficult to pull off
and are so often regarded as cheesy and
ham-fisted instead of
having that emotional punch that they're
going for that said you could argue that
musicals will hit you in the fifis in a
quick and potent way
so a good book adaptation will distill
the novel's emotional core
and turn it into song a successful
musical will find that emotional core of
the story
and use music to express that kidnapping
a young soprano through means of
deception
and hypnotizing make it a romantic song
and
listen to the music
according to new yorker staff writer
adam gopnik on les miserables
the real absence from novel to musical
is rooted in the dna of the musical
theater
which welcomes big emotions but not
always too complicated or ambivalent
ones
while the rent bemoaning gravity-defying
musicals of today seem like the
product of a relatively young art form
musical theater comes from a long
tradition of storytelling that has its
roots in
opera where plot and dialogue are moved
primarily through song music
and operetta more dialogue driven and
lighter and usually more comedic in tone
but even some of the most popular operas
were adapted from
books such as poutines la boheme and don
zanetti's lucia de la memor
not to mention the scores of operas
based on shakespearean works like
verdi zotelo or gunos romeo and juliet
you get the idea
so flash forward to the 1920s when the
vaudeville vignette style of musical was
in vogue
and the songs rarely moved the plot
forward and were more showcases for
dancing and singing
in comes jerome kern and oscar
hammerstein the second
1927 musical showboat based on edna
ferber's 1926 novel of the same name
record fast turn over there here songs
like old man river and can't help love
and dat man
drove the story forward discussing
complex themes of tragic love and racial
prejudice
and without the promise of just being
popcorn entertainment
such as it were from there the book
musical i.e a
musical play where songs and dancing are
integrated fully into
a story with emotional and dramatic
goals not a musical based on a book
exploded into popularity and it is from
this era that we get
many classics of the genre adapted from
books
however it's starting in the 1980s we
really start
seeing shows veer into thing you've
heard of
the musical territory where musicals are
not just based on books
but that adaptation is the selling point
musicals based on books continue to be
big business even love never dies the
famous disaster sequel to phantom of the
opera
is based on a published book oh yeah
it's called
the phantom of manhattan and it was
written by acclaimed mystery writer
frederick forsyth
also shout out to lestat the musical
based on anne rice's vampire chronicles
and yes i paid to see
twice best 20 i ever spent
so despite the enduring popularity of
musicals based on books
it must needs be remarked that when we
talk about musical theater and its
relationship to books
there is something of a lingering
snobbery
in his 1936 essay the work of art in the
age of mechanical reproduction
walter benjamin claimed that every
original work of art has an aura of
authenticity that is gradually stripped
away by the process of copying and
reproduction
film scholar and my advanced project
professor at nyu film robert stam
has argued literature will always have
an axiomatic superiority
over other forms of adaptation because
of its seniority as an art form
this hierarchy also has something to do
with what he calls
iconophobia the suspicion of the visual
and the concomitant
logophilia the love of the word is
sacred from this perspective
adaptations are by definition belated
middlebrow or
culturally inferior however other
scholars have argued that there is a
middle ground or a place for adaptation
in other forms of media
in her essay on the art of adaptation
professor and literary theorist linda
hutchins says
while no medium is inherently good at
doing one thing and not another
each medium like each genre has
different means of expression and so can
aim at
certain things better than others if the
artist has a paintbrush
his or her vision of the same landscape
will emerge as
masses instead a poet by the same
analogy will be attracted to
representing different aspects of a
story
than the creator of a musical
spectacular so if we did an in-depth
analysis of this topic with lots of
different musicals as examples
this episode would be as long as well
les mis but this is pbs it's a
non-profit we don't have that kind of
budget
so let's look at some musical
adaptations that turned into big hits
what did they change and what did they
keep gregory mcguire's 1995 novel wicked
makes for a great example of how
adaptation can completely change the
tone of the original source material
while still retaining the plot elements
that made it compelling
based on l frank baum's wizard of oz
books wicked is told from the point of
view of
the wicked witch of the west or as she
is referred to in the novel
elphaba throp while the musical is a
bubbly high-energy pop pastiche about
her backstory
the novel is a way more nihilistic and
detached and
much more concerned with the racial
justice subtext of oz
and elphaba's fight against injustice
steven swartz musical adaptation takes
that and completely changes the tone
recasting elphaba and galinda the good
witch of the north
as two young women exploring how their
friendship changes as they grow up
together
wicked the musical smartly understood
that while the source material
was popular for a reason what people
want in a musical
is slightly queer-coded film stories
between a dark-haired woman and a blonde
with songs about being a magical hashtag
girl boss
which is to say that it is basically a
disney musical complete with an i want
song a power ballad
tacked on unnecessary hetero love story
animal fun times and a happy ending
that was not there in the novel but
where wicked seems like an obvious pick
for a musical adaptation
what could seem less obvious than a
musical based on the life of the united
states first treasury secretary
alexander hamilton well if the musical
feels extremely biased towards hamilton
a lot of that is because ron chernow the
guy who wrote the biography off of which
the musical is based
is extremely biased towards alexander
hamilton he loves the guy
so while the show is about this one
guy's life as written by chernob
it expands that by a way of theme of who
lives who dies
who tells your story knowing and
accepting
that you can't control how people will
frame your place in history after you're
gone
miranda's major change is focusing on
the exploration of legacy as an
emotional experience rather than an
intellectual or academic one
miranda worked closely with chernob to
bring in the multiracial casting as a
specific feature of the theatrical
production
miranda says his intent was to tell a
story about america then
told by american now using different
styles of music and dance
specifically hip hop in a way that you
just can't do with a book
according to miranda we want to
eliminate any distance
our story should look the way our
country looks then we found the best
people to embody these parts
i think it's a very powerful statement
without having to be a statement
but if we're going by sheer ambition
versus execution perhaps the biggest
success story is
bibliolyn schoenberg's 1985 musical les
miserables
or as we call it in the theater kid
community les mis
according to the oxford handbook of the
british musical a thing that exists
the novel spiritual and sentimental
tones necessarily become simpler
and more forceful in a song through
musical that is played out on a
theatrical stage
the musical echoes hugo but understands
that his narrative range and depth could
not be merely recited
if it were to succeed as a modern opera
based on victor hugo's book of the same
name which is approximately 60 000 pages
long
how does one distill the emotional core
of this book and render it into song
well here's what we got
the revolutionary subplot jean valjean's
personal journey
and of course young love what is telling
is what is cut out the book is very
concerned with french history
the musical i mean it's there but less
so there's a huge chunk in the second
half of the novel that goes back to the
battle of waterloo and explains that for
a few hundred pages
in the musical it gets a passing mention
he was there
[Music]
but it's never the focus the show keys
in on the big emotions
both macro the political movement
embodied with songs like
do you hear the people singing
and the micro the personal emotional
journeys of the characters
to again cite that oxford musical
handbook whether personal taste
accommodates the mega musical genre or
not
the fact remains that les miserables has
become the foremost example of this
musical form
by successfully intensifying the
original novel's melodrama
and of course it would not be an episode
that i co-wrote
without a mention of our sad boy our
favorite literary trash can
the phantom of the opera andrew lloyd
webber claims that a chance finding of
gaston larue's 1910 novel
was the thing that inspired what would
become the most successful broadway
musical in history
this novel has everything kidnapping
extortion
a fallen chandelier a torture chamber in
the guest bedroom
the musical cuts that part out but
although he saw incredible potential
there since the novel was originally
serialized
it was also kind of all over the place
said lloyd webber
the gaston larue novel is a very
confused confection
sometimes a faux history story then
sporting a touch of
george de moyer's novel trilby next to
horror story
then it's french detective time now and
then it's spiced with beauty and the
beast with a dash of satanic paganini
also the phantom's name has got to go in
the very first treatment lloyd webber
wrote for the musical he notes
also in the novel he's called eric no
way eric the musical
bad title so what does lord andy horn in
on in this somewhat tonally inconsistent
novel with an underwhelming name for the
lead
simple it's a tragic romance about
unrequited love
the novel has the seeds of this story of
unrequited love among many other things
but lloyd webber decided that should be
the primary focus
so the musical makes the phantom in lord
andy's words
no monster but a handsome hug
michael crawford sex adonis
he has this hypnotic power and christine
is drawn to his musical genius
lloyd webber also took elements that
happened off-screen or were
teased in the novel and turned it up to
11 for maximum musical melodrama
again lord andy here was the plot i
could fashion into the high romance i
had been longing to write
the phantom has composed his own
passionate opera for pristine to perform
comet's performance the phantom acts out
his wildest fantasy by taking the lead
opposite her himself
christine publicly shames him by
unmasking him in front of the entire
opera house
and when did christine give the phantom
back the ring it's not in larue's novel
so while eric the phantom was always a
tragic sympathetic character
the major change here is to make him
relatable
arguably the audience is meant to relate
more to the phantom than to anyone else
in the show
in revisiting his opinion of les
miserables 25 years after the show
opened the guardian theater critic
michael billington who originally
trashed the show
had this to say in retrospect what i
find intriguing is that we think we live
in a very cool smart cynical age
yet when the chips are down what we
really crave is a contest of good and
evil
and lashings of spectacle it's easy to
be down on a musical adaptation in the
book just in the same way it's easy to
be down on a film adaptation
but literary and media studies have been
making a case for the power and mart
form of musical adaptation for years
as pulitzer prize-winning new york times
theater critic brooks atkinson put it
as an art form the musical stage is
entitled a serious consideration
by the richness of its medium which
blends music dance
first costume scenery and orchestra the
musical drama makes complete use of the
theater
it is the one element left in a form of
literature that was all
poetry originally so while it is sad
that broadway has been dark for the
longest time in its history
if the success of hamilton on disney
tell us anything
the love is still there
you